je viens de parler à mes mes conseillers
en affaires de sécurité nationale qui
m'assurent qu'on est en train de tout
faire pour assurer la sécurité des
canadiens et on continue à travailler
avec nos alliés à travers le monde avec
une vigilance accrue évidemment c'était
la réaction de justin trudeau h au
vendredi juste après justin au
dénouement de la crise a pas à paris à
ce moment là certains vous direct
comme emmanuel laborde est tout à
l'heure que la réaction aujourd'hui n'a
pas tellement changé ça de quoi
alimenter la discussion avec notre panel
se partagent les présente un angle
minsky elle est analyste politique qui a
radio canada malan bonjour et pas aux
rédacteurs en chef du bureau politique
du magazine maclean's à ottawa bonjour
pas le bon jour
en commençant par vous manon à vous avez
entendu la réaction vous étiez là
vendredi
ça c'est pas tellement changé et il n'y
a pas beaucoup de substance là dedans il
était un peu plus au dépourvu monsieur
trudeau d'abord il a été très ébranlée
je pense qu'on le säntis vendredi au
départ très très solennelle en arrivant
au micro grand sourire avant de
commencer à parler et une seule question
à laquelle il n'a pas répondu à une
question inévitable certainement est-ce
que ce qui se passe à paris où vous
donne matière à réflexion pour changer
votre promesse de faire cesser les
frappes aériennes canadiennes
est ce que vous pourriez par exemple ne
pas modifier la loi antiterroriste
adoptée par le gouvernement
et monsieur trudeau ne répond pas ça
vous dit ça n'a pas beaucoup changé je
pense que là on a la preuve de
l'inexpérience d'un jeune premier
ministre qui vient vraiment d'arriver
qui s'en allait vraiment très
sereinement vers un sommet du g20 et
ensuite le sommet de l'apec où il allait
s'entretenir pour la première fois avec
les grands de ce monde et la réalité qui
le rattrape
c'est assez difficile de s'adapter
qu'est-ce que vous qui soyez comme
réaction vous quand vous la regardez je
suis moins certains qui est qu'on est en
face de votre premier disque qui ne sait
pas où aller garder le cap c'est aussi
une qualité en politique
allez parler de l'économie un sommet du
g20
garder une certaine marge de manoeuvre
comme on a vu avec votre entrevue avec
avec dominic leblanc ce matin ils ne
disent pas qu'ils vont ils ne vont pas
changer leurs normes et pratiques sur
les cf-18 et sur les réfugiés
ils disent que pour l'instant il voit
toujours les mêmes raisons de soutenir
ces politiques là mais je pense qu'il y
aura des discussions assez assez poussée
entre ministres ici au canada et en
turquie dans les prochains jours entre
garder le cap entre garder le cap et et
et ne rien ne rien dire ne rien annoncer
ce qui est injuste le milieu que je te
donnerai à dieu
c'est sûr que je protège la perception
de maintenant ils avaient l'air ébranlé
il vendredi soir et c'est sûr que ce
sont ses premiers sauts mais ce sont ses
premiers voyages des étrangers y compris
ministre il
c'était très important pour lui de
marquer un certain coût en maillant de
déduire des choses à dire là tout est
bousculée c'est sûr que c'est difficile
pour nous une certaine façon juste être
d'autres doit jouer avec la main qu'il a
et c'est sur que c'est pas un barack
obama par exemple barack obama arrive au
sommet du g20 antalya il se rajoute une
bilatérale avec le roi d'arabie saoudite
qui est aussi sur place
justin trudeau n'est pas de ces joueurs
là et il doit d'abord et avant tout
c'était son but rétablir l'image du
canada dans le monde à table et établir
aussi son sérieux à lui qui arrive sur
la scène internationale donc c'est
difficile pour nous de vouloir le voir
comme comme un joueur de talent est là
dessus ce serait vraiment trop lui
demander à ce point en ce moment mais de
là à dire par exemple ce qu'ils ont fait
aujourd'hui au sommet du g20 c'est à
dire maintenir une annonce de millions
de dollars en impôts des dans
l'infrastructure à l'indonésie un
partenariat avec la banque mondiale chez
moi bon ça c'est dur c'est vous c'est
vraiment très très difficile de trouver
un juste milieu entre ce qu'on avait
prévu faire et comment il faut modifier
comment il faut s'adapter
compte tenu des évènements
vous avez attentivement écouté discours
de monsieur hollande hier vous avez noté
ce langage qu'il a utilisé la france est
en guerre et ça ça dit en application au
1 au niveau de l'otan canada fait partie
de l'otan maintenant soulever tout à
l'heure le fait que bon est ce qu ont
encore les moyens de réviser ses 51 de
mettre un terme à l'utilisation des
chasseurs là bas comment vous voyez ça
dans le contexte soulevé par par le
temps c'est vrai que lorsque le premier
ministre et le président de la france
par deux donne acte de guerre il se peut
qu'ils interpellent d'autant mercredi
prochain il ya la réunion hebdomadaire
de conseil de l'otan à bruxelles
il se peut que la france demande de
l'aide à ses ailiers de façon fort mais
ça ne s'était fait qu'une fois le 11
septembre 2001 ouest et est donc c'est
peu probable mais il ya un joueur
important dans toute cette histoire qui
est absent qui n'est plus dans ça aussi
et brand le premier ministre stephen
harper parce que lorsque les 16 18 ans
en iran qui était la politique de
stephen harper s'était facile pour un
chef d'opposition de réagir de gagner à
réagir mais là c'est la france attaquée
c'est le gouvernement socialiste qui
donnent la réplique
les répliques c'est le premier disque du
québec qui souhaite l'implication du
canada
c'est très différent parce que ça fait
partie de la prudence qu'on a entendu
chez dominique leblanc tout à l'heure
c'est à dire que monsieur leblanc fait
comme monsieur dion a fait hier c'est à
dire maintenir la promesse que le canada
va cesser de participer aux frappes
aériennes mais continuer de contribuer à
la condition ça c'est très important
pour pour ce gouvernement est de le
préciser mais en même temps on sentait
monsieur leblanc prudent quand il dit il
faut consulter nos alliés il faut
travailler avec nos alliés je pense que
paul le dessus tout à fait raison le
temps les obligations que nous impose
une pause au canada l'article 5 de
l'otan sont des obligations qu'il faut
pas négliger et je pense que juste être
doux ça aussi le le sait maintenant est
ce qui sera aussi faut compléter stephen
harper on a entendu madame aime blues il
la leader intérim artistes amateurs mais
moi j'ai trouvé que madame rose c'était
peut-être un peu vite
honnêtement je pense qu'on aurait pas là
pour l'instant le canada est impliqué
jusqu'en mars 2016
donc on n'a pas ça pas été l'élection
justin trudeau et le retour des des f-18
au canada là ils sont encore là il
participe en encore entendu parler de
frappe
la semaine dernière donc peut-être
justement on se pose des questions sur
la réponse de justin trudeau mais
justement il n'y a pas de demande encore
voit la guerre ça présuppose une conseil
de guerre il y en a pas jusqu à
maintenant voyons voir ça de la semaine
j'aimerais aborder la question des
réfugiés syriens parce que là on va voir
on va voir tout cela est arrivé sous une
toute nouvelle lorgnette on veut
toujours autres comédiens du côté du
gouvernement cette volonté de faire
venir va être 5000 réfugiés seuil et au
canada d'ici la fin de l'année est ce
que dans le contexte des attaques de
paris c'est encore c'est encore une
nécessité est ce qu'on devrait pourvoir
le l'échéancier là dessus et surtout
qu'on a trouvé un passeport de quelqu'un
qui a un qui était supposément tu arrivé
depuis la grâce de la série c'est sûr
que sur mon compte twitter jean reçoit
déjà des demandes et des gens qui disent
sur 25000 personnes
s'il y en avait un sur mille qui dit
qu'ils avaient des intentions d'être
néfastes sur la catastrophe
il se peut qu'on ralentisse
l'accueil de ces réfugiés là mais là
encore il dominic leblanc qu'est le
premier ministre n'ont pas encore changé
de cap sur sa politique mais encore le 1
sur 8
enfin en france c'est les autres
citoyens français vivant en france
vivent en belgique donc pas
nécessairement des gens qui sont venus à
paris précisément pour pour ça on parle
beaucoup de cellules dormantes de mode
d'opération semblable à ceux d'al qaïda
jadis donc est ce que vraiment dans ces
réfugiés là il ya pas que comme le
soulignent les ministres gouvernement
des gens qui fuient
le groupe armé islamique est ce que
c'est pas sûr tout ça et est ce que ne
pas les accueillir
c'est pas plutôt favorisé donner un
argument de recrutement de plus à ces
organisations mai mais est ce que la
caution sociale qui est nécessaire pour
ce genre d'opération là et pas un peu
diminués par les attaques de vendredi
est ce qu'il ya un danger de ce côté
c'est ce qu'il ya de la nervosité dans
les populations occidentaux on a lu dans
le new york times ce matin analyse comme
quoi l'état islamique semble avoir
changé de stratégie pour ne plus se
concentrer sur la région du moyen orient
et justement pour aller donner l'état
qu'elle est d'attaqué l'étranger si
c'est un vrai changement de stratégie de
détail dynamique ça change ça change
aussi ça devrait changer aussi la
réponse des états occidentaux
c'est une vingtaine de secondes on sait
que le gouvernement la stratégie du
gouvernement est prête c'est qu'ils
s'apprêtaient à l'annoncé est ce qui va
vraiment peut-être attendre un peu faire
preuve de prudence c'est possible avant
même qu'ils l'annoncent on s'appelait
dans la population qu'on on pressent
qu'on tolérait que ça prenne un petit
peu plus probablement manon globensky
par l'oise merci beaucoup à vous deux
merci